ow  welcome to the 20th anniversary  celebration of hedvig and the angry inch  i keep meeting people who were effective  i had big have you heard of hedwig and  the anchorage i'm like that's me no  right it just doesn't stop it's still  relevant and still beautiful it has  fostered a conversation with strangers  about meaning and purpose i've heard of  multiple people saying when i start  dating someone if they don't like it we  don't continue dating when people come  up and say it meant something to them it  makes it more impactful to me too it  keeps giving it's like the personal ad  that never goes out of circulation who  are you where do you exist when do you  get to make that decision and have big  ask that question with music which is  the most visceral way to ask a question  that is the most empowering compliment  any artist can have is that it made  someone feel that they could do  something they didn't know they could  that has helped them  [Music]  you